Vice President Mike Pence told European
allies in Poland this morning that they
should join the US and pull out of the
Iran nuclear deal hence called Iran the
world's biggest state sponsor of
terrorism during a conference to promote
security in the Middle East the agenda
does not include Saudi Arabia's conflict
with Yemen and it's reported role in the
killing of Washington Post columnist
Jamal khashoggi Roxana Saberi asks
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo why the
administration is still backing the
Saudis and their de facto leader the
Trump administration has been very
critical about human rights violations
in Iran but when it comes to America's
allies such as Saudi Arabia it seems
that the u.s. is less critical for
example Mohammed bin Salman the Crown
Prince is believed by the CIA to have
been involved in the killing of American
resident Jamal [ __ ] do you believe the
CIA's assessment rocks and that's a
ridiculous question why that's a
ridiculous question the United States
calls out human rights violations each
place that we find them yet President
Trump has been more hesitant to
criticize Mohammed bin Salman we have an
important relationship with the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia we are determined to
make that a successful relationship but
we've made clear as the facts are
development as we learn more we hold
everyone responsible for the murder of
Jamal khashoggi accountable Saudi Arabia
why that was such a ridiculous question
yeah I'm not sure either Saudi Arabians
since the Crown Prince did not order
kosher geez murder